not too long ago you hosted one of these
shows when The Late Late Show was was
Late Late Show was in transition I guess
yeah they were having people come in and
guess yes
and they brought you in to host the show
for a night which is pretty you know
that's a rare experience yeah how was it
for you how'd you like doing it so I'm
obsessed the talk shows and I covet your
job and I'm here to take it from you
okay and no I just really love the form
and I was friendly with the Craig
Ferguson show and and so yeah when they
asked me to do it I like jumped at it
and then I realized it's a job you
prepare for for a really long time you
don't just like step in for one night
and kind of like you know host but I did
and I think it's actually would I mean
why not why not go in and do it for a
night and just give it a shot how did it
feel - did it feel like this is
something you could do over and over
again well I loved it I mean I loved the
experience and I don't know I mean
you've been doing it for 22 years I I
think you might go crazy at a certain
point what you say
[Music]
ya know if you know what you've done
Andy's in the corner crying bud well you
know no I wouldn't say you go crazy but
yeah it gets surreal at moments there
there's a Groundhog Day to it every day
and so you get to a point where we're
just doing things to sort of try and
shock each other well also there's so
much dependent on who you're talking to
and I had a couple of friends I invited
to do the show and even they were hard
to follow at times and I don't know if
you're dealing with complete strangers
but I guess I loved doing it and I
wished I could have done it more to kind
of get in a groove or sort of find the
way I would do it over time well I am
sure I'm gonna have a skiing accident
very soon you should but you should good
I'm going to be very badly hurt very
soon I'm telling you June skis
underrated and I think you should step
right in if that happens and take over I
do what Andy would get along great
I yes you give me good celebrity
jeopardy advice that's another topic yes
oh but the other thing that was crazy
about doing this show was Whitney
Cummings had done it kind of in a
different form but of the people who did
it in that write that studio it was the
only woman right who did it which I just
thought was crazy oh you think that ya
know obviously you think women should be
in late-night yeah
I feel like I'm doing my part and that
I'm the closest of the men to a woman I
think there are nights when I could go
either way and so thank you whoo